house of the dragon the massively
anticipated prequel to game of thrones
is going to hit our screens next year
and one of the stars of the original
series has commented on the new show's
trailer
nikolai costa waldo who played jaime
lannister in game of thrones has given
his reaction to the teaser
he said that he came away intrigued and
added i thought it was fun to see matt
smith in that world in that beautiful
white wig
and listen
i'm curious as everyone to see it
the danish actor went on to say
but it is a very different show it's his
own show i just hope it's great i hope
the success of game of thrones won't get
in the way for people when they
experience this new show
for us it took a while for people to get
into game of thrones
i remember the first season people were
saying
there are too many characters i don't
know what's going on
i don't think they have the luxury we
had
they have to start with where we were in
like season four or five
because that's what they will be
compared to
but i really hope that it's a massive
hit for them
the prequel has an interesting
foundation on which to lay its first
bricks
it follows undoubtedly the biggest tv
show in the world
but one that had a disappointing ending
on the one hand it should be less of a
challenge to improve on what came
directly before but on the other hand
game of thrones is still a beast of a
series to step into the shoes of
costa waldo rightly points out that the
show is going to have high expectations
right from the off and won't be given
the grace period to slow burn like the
early seasons of game of thrones
it's going to have the expectation of a
caged dragon in that it's going to be
expected to come out of the traps
quickly as well as scale the incredible
heights of its predecessor
but despite all this it's clear that
costa waldo is as excited as the fans
regardless of how game of thrones ended
it's clear there's a massive appetite
for house of the dragon and there's
already plenty of support for the other
prequels waiting in the wings to make a
tv airing
when house of the dragon finally makes
it to our screens next year perhaps
costa waldo will let us all know what he
thinks of the premiere